So one thing I try to avoid talking about,
um, for reasons that you'll understand why
in a moment I tried to avoid talking about
the Democratic primaries, not because I don't
have very strong opinions on each candidate,
uh, but because we have a fascist in the White
House and, um, I think we need to govern ourselves
accordingly and what we love to do more than
anything else, uh, because I participated
in it and I understand how, um, how easy it
is to get caught up in the divides on the
left side of the spectrum.
Now may I remind you that is a really big
range, right?
That um, that includes centrist Democrats
who are basically conservative, particularly
on the international spectrum.
A centrist Democrats are further to the right
then, uh, or equally to the right as, uh,
the, the Tories in the UK.
Uh, so when we say the American left, we really
are talking about a really broad range of
people basically who aren't Republican.
And that goes from centrist Democrats all
the way to communist Socialist Marxist Leninist.
There's a very big range.
But when we talk about the, the, the, the
primaries, uh, it becomes very easy for us
to engage in this inter party, um, intraparty
battle.
Um, basically for what this party is going
to look like, what the Democratic Party is
going to look like.
And included in that are, are some people
who, um, have similar politics to us, but
their approach to this is burn it all down.
Burn the entire Democratic Party down.
There's nothing we can do it.
Burn it all down.
Uh, and, and let's, let's commence with the
revolution.
More power to you.
We have a fascist in the White House, right?
So when election day comes around, govern
yourselves accordingly.
Now, all that said, I wanted to make sure
that you understood why I'm coming from.
Um, all that said, there's a lot of interesting
things happening in this primary, uh, uh,
and we haven't even begun the primaries in
earnest.
Um, Bernie Sanders was here in Atlanta this
weekend.
Uh, he made a couple of gaps, um, in response
to questions from the audience.
I was actually there in person and I like
Bernie Sanders.
I'm actually a huge Bernie Sanders supporter.
Um, generally, uh, like all of his policies.
Um, I just, just from following him though,
I think it's safe to say that is there any
standards in a way is not the revolutionary.
Uh, he's a politician.
Um, you know, listening to his answers to
the questions I, you know, you could see him
calculating like a politician calculates to
make sure that he doesn't commit overcommit
under commit and tries to say the price precise
thing.
I think he's far more a standard politician
than we would like to believe.
And I say that as a Bernie Sanders supporter.
However, um, he's very closely tied in my
opinion with Elizabeth Warren who has her
policies.
Like we, we've coined her policy, Bay Hashtag
Policy Bay because he has plans, right?
And in a way it's like what Bernie Sanders
has the moral clarity on.
Um, Elizabeth Warren is demonstrating that
she can make a plan to implement it.
And so she has a plan for that.
And so for me, those are the top two in my
personal running.
And that's just my personal opinion.
Like every single one of you is going to have
a different opinion and that's fine.
I think it's important for us to be able to
talk about the good and the bad in each of
our candidates.
Right?
I think the most critical thing for us in
this primary is to not fall back into, um,
the vice of, of being more interested in fighting
internally then realizing the fight that we
have externally with conservatives.
Uh, because we are at a pivotal time in American
history.
I can't overstate, I, I, I can't say this
dramatic enough, right?
There's no amount of hyperbole that I can
wrap this next sentence in to convey you.
The severity of this, of what's going on,
what Donald Trump has done already is going
to take almost a full generation for us to
undo.
When you think of his some 100 or more, uh,
judicial picks throughout the judiciary, the
federal judiciary, when you think about his
pixel on the Supreme Court, uh, particularly
Cavenaugh will you think about the, the massive
sweep of, um, of policies of, of passing bills,
antiabortion bills specifically with the purposes
of overturning Roe vs Wade.
And now we have a conservative majority on
the bench and it's very possible that that
could happen.
The damage that Donald Trump is doing.
And uh, his one term, it's going to take us
a lifetime.
I mean, an entire generation if I'm around,
if I haven't gone crazy or are like, you know,
whatever, I have a full beard of white hairs
instead of the one or two that I have.
By the time we're able to undo what Donald
Trump has done, unless we get some Democrats
who are strong enough and radical enough to
actually shake this system up.
Right.
You're like, can we afford to wait an entire
generation for abortions to be legal again
in this country?
Or do we need Democrats who are willing to
talk about packing the courts in 2020.
So as we look at the primaries, it's important
and I think it's, it think it's meaningful
for us to argue.
It's meaningful for us to be able to look
at the differences between each of these candidates
and to clearly delineate the good, the bad,
the ugly, and the indifferent.
Like Joe Biden, right?
While he's pulling wonderfully and he's doing
wonderful in the polls, um, you know, he's
really doing wonderful in the polls because
of Barack Obama, right?
Joe Biden has a lot of baggage that he has
to take account for.
He has to be accountable.
He has to explain, he has to be able to tell
America and he's actually taking the opposite,
of course.
Right?
He's saying that he is not going to apologize
for anything.
Well, that's going to be a hard road for Joe
Biden and, um, that's gonna be a problem.
Mayor Pete [inaudible].
Pete doesn't really have any accomplishments.
Um, not many to speak of.
I mean, I know a lot of prolific, I don't
know a lot of dynamic mayors across the city.
Um, but what mayor Pete does have really well,
and I don't mean this as an insult, as a great
team, a great PR team, a great team of people
who know how to amplify him into the national
conversation.
Um, you know, so there, there are candidates
who, who are going to be, how do I say this?
I don't want to, I don't want to be offensive
because I don't want to let clip be used,
uh, as a way of dividing us.
But I'll just say it like this.
There's going to be good and bad in each of
these candidates.
Some are going to have more good, some are
going to have more bad.
And that's the entire purpose of the primaries.
We have to fight it out.
We have to hash it out.
But you can't have it.
And listen, another thing for a lot of people
who are still Bernie or busters, um, you cannot
win this fight outside of the Democratic Party.
You're like, you need to register.
You need to register to vote.
I mean, that was a big impediment last time.
A lot of people had not registered to vote.
They were fighting, they were online and they
were, they were intense about their participation
online, but they didn't get and registered
by the deadline.
And if you believe that the democratic establishment
is going to sandbag Bernie Sanders, then you
have to vote in numbers that they can't deny.
Right.
And, and then even more so there's an opportunity,
there has been opportunities for people to
get involved in these parties.
And when I say parties, I mean the local parties
and to participate so that, that those types
of shenanigans don't happen in your precinct.
So it's, it's a huge battle that we have going
on that's going to continue.
And rightfully so.
I'm not telling anyone to not fight about
the primaries.
I'm saying have it out, you know, be sober
about your own candidate.
Like I'm very sober.
I Like Elizabeth Warren, but I'm bear.
I am very keen to the idea are not keen to
the idea that that I want, I want to say I'm
very cognizant of the reality that she's going
to have a hell of a fight with Donald Trump
winning the general election because of how
easily Donald Trump attacks her in a way that
previously has almost neutralized or, so I
want to see that particular fight and I have
problems with some of her foreign policy.
Similarly, Bernie Sanders, he has a couple
of blind spots that he's had for a long time.
I won't talk about them now.
You can go to my channel and see some of those
videos, but there's things that we have to
be realistic about, about each and every one
of our candidates.
And I think for us they have a fair assessment.
We need to be honest about the pros and cons
about our candidates.
Just like we're honest about the cons of the
people that we don't want to become the nominee.
But all that said, when it's all said and
done, I just have to emphasize and maybe you
would, maybe we need a daily reminder no matter
how bad, oh, I forgot about a couple of common
law, like you know, all the things that she
is and things that she's not.
I just want to emphasize that we have a fascist
in the White House and authoritarian who would
gladly be a dictator who ignores the rule
of law, who thinks he's above the law, who
ignores checks and balances, who uses the,
the bully pulpit of demagoguery to get his
way currently in the White House.
So honestly, as unpopular as the statement
is, no matter how bad any of these Democrats
are, there are 100% better than the fascist
is sitting in the White House.
Now, my hope is going to be that it will be
Bernie or Elizabeth Warren or a combination
thereof.
Um, but whoever wins, I'm telling you now,
I'm throwing on their tee shirt and I'm going
door to door.
Thanks so much for hanging out with me today.
Um, David, we'll be back and we will see you
later.